[Musica]
tra 15 anni chiuderà l'elettricità più
per le auto che per la luce
anche appartiene questa frase che disse
jeff bezos
ok
chi dice mask
ok è un'idea veda ancora qualcuno in
deciso forse avete ragione ben decisi
perché tra 15 anni chiuderà
l'elettricità più per le auto che per la
luce è una frase di thomas edison
pronunciata nel 1910
e oggi dopo cent'anni vediamo che le
nostre strade sono tutte ben illuminate
ma di auto elettriche non ne vediamo
tante
com'è possibile che un genio come lui
avesse sbagliato di così tanto nella sua
previsione che cosa ha dato storto
io mi occupo di ricerca in ambito
motoristico e oggi vi condurrà nel
percorso della rivoluzione che coinvolge
l'auto elettrica
vedremo che questo percorso non è così
lineare come sembra
immaginate una calda per estiva uscita a
fare un giro in bicicletta e attaccate
la dinamo pedalare diventa subito più
difficile
sentite questo maggiore sforzo con le
gambe
dovete non solo muovere la bicicletta ma
dovete dare una maggiore energia a un
maggiore movimento anche la dinamo che
trasforma questa nostra fatica in
elettricità e la lampadina trasforma
questa elettricità in luce produrre
energia elettrica non è gratis
il ciclista può essere definito come una
fonte di energia rinnovabile nessuno ha
mai visto uscire fumo nero dei poli di
un ciclista al massimo un po di sudore
ma quando si parla di motori elettrici
cambia qualcosa
tutto dipende da chi sta pedalando al
posto nostro
se l'energia proviene da una centrale
che brucia a carbone gas e petrolio
allora la nostra auto elettrica non
inquina tanto meno di un motore diesel o
benzina l'auto elettrica non inquina
solo quando la fonte che fornisce
elettricità è una fonte rinnovabile come
la luce del sole il vento o il moto
dell'acqua
bisogna però considerare che nel mondo
solo il 30 per cento e dell'energia
prodotta proviene da fonti rinnovabili e
in europa andiamo un po meglio questa
percentuale sale al 46 per cento anche
se non siamo proprio degli angioletti
più della metà dell'energia elettrica
che consumiamo in europa proviene da
paesi extraeuropei quindi il mondo
inquina anche a causa nostra
la chiave è produrre tanta energia
elettrica usando fonti rinnovabili
magari usando pannelli fotovoltaici pale
eoliche o turbina idroelettrica
massimo veramente capaci di muoverci
sulle nostre strade esistenti inquinare
faremo un viaggio
andremo in norvegia poi in giappone e
poi torneremo in italia
in norvegia vedremo un estremo in
giappone un altro estremo e l'italia è
un po nel mezzo
la norvegia ha un record nel 2020 è il
primo stato al mondo che vende più auto
elettriche cauto tradizionali questo
dato da solo non ci basta dobbiamo anche
considerare che più del 90 per cento e
dell energia elettrica norvegese e
proviene da fonti rinnovabili sono le
turbine idroelettriche che pedalano per
loro quindi zero inquinamento in
norvegia abbiamo tante auto elettriche
che consumano energia elettrica che non
inquina
andiamo quindi dall'altra parte del
mondo andiamo in giappone il giappone ha
un altro record nel 2003 di salewa più
colonnine per la ricarica elettrica che
non pompe di benzina e negli anni questo
trend si è mantenuto e quindi non ci
sorprende che il giappone se la pace di
toyota leader mondiali nel settore delle
auto elettriche ed ibride e non ci
sorprende neanche allora che il giappone
voglia mettere al bando tutte le auto
tradizionali a partire dal 2035
quello che allora ci deve sorprendere e
ciò che ha affermato l'amministratore
delegato di toyota nel dicembre del 2020
più auto elettriche produrremo ep
inquineremo
non suona strano anche a voi e non vi
suonerà più così strano perché l'ottanta
per cento dell'energia elettrica
giapponese viene prodotta a partire da
combustibili fossili gas petrolio
carbone e quindi in giappone abbiamo
tante auto elettrica
ma sullo sfondo tanto fumo nero di
queste centrali
torniamo a casa nostra non torniamo in
italia l'italia un po nel mezzo il 35
per cento dell'energia elettrica
italiana viene prodotta a partire da
fonti rinnovabili regista ma anche dando
da fare
nel gennaio del 2000 e 21 il ministero
dello sviluppo economico ha creato un
bando per incentivare l'acquisto di auto
poco inquinanti
sono stati stanziati
250 milioni di euro per incentivare
l'acquisto di auto tradizionali poco
inquinanti masa dizionari e ad oggi gli
italiani hanno dato tutti questi fondi
il ministero però aveva stanziato anche
120 milioni di euro per l'acquisto di
auto elettrica e ad oggi e prato dato
soltanto il 60 per cento di questa somma
46 milioni sono ancora fermi
inutilizzati
tutto il mondo sta andando in una
direzione e quando tutto il mondo va
nella stessa direzione i risultati
arrivano sempre
quindi la rivoluzione elettrica della
mobilità è inevitabile ma è anche
necessaria perché ci dà la possibilità
di muoverci sulle nostre strade sta in
cinquina re basti pensare all'esempio di
esplosa della norvegia
tutto il mondo sta quindi andando nella
stessa direzione ma non siamo tutti lo
stesso livello
ci dobbiamo chiedere quanto tempo ci
manca ma anche quanto tempo abbiamo a
disposizione
io non ho la risposta a queste domande
ma voglio farvi riflettere su un
componente centrale e delle auto
elettrica le batterie
torniamo alla suggerì bicicletta si è
veramente caldissimo non vogliamo
faticare ulteriormente compriamo delle
batterie le colleghiamo alla nostra
lampadina e premendo un bottone abbiamo
tutta la luce che ci serve senza
faticare
dobbiamo però chiedersi quanto costano
queste batterie
quanto durano e quando tempi impieghiamo
per ricaricarle quando si parla di auto
elettriche abbiamo le risposte una
batteria costa fra i tremila euro per
un'utilitaria fino a 40mila euro per una
supercar facilmente un quarto del valore
dell'auto
possiamo percorrere 400 chilometri e per
ricaricarle totalmente possono essere
necessari anche otto ore
se però un'altra domanda a cui non
sappiamo rispondere
dove buttiamo queste batterie una volta
che sono diventate vecchia e anche
l'europa se questo si è fatta questa
domanda e per trovare una risposta ha
stanziato un miliardo di euro da
investire nella ricerca delle batterie e
nello specifico come smaltirli
correttamente infatti le batterie sono
ricche di materie altamente inquinanti
anche il mondo dell'automotive sta
andando in questa direzione è una
notizia di marzo 2021 che audi ha
sospeso qualsiasi investimento nelle
auto diesel e benzina
e anche altre aziende stanno andando
nella stessa direzione
sembra che vogliono sopprimere motore a
combustione interna prima del tempo
ma dobbiamo chiederci quante risorse
servono per preparare strade e quindi né
per la ricarica per l'imminente frittura
dell'auto elettrica e io personalmente
mi faccio alcuna domanda o fidato per
anni moser a combustione interna deve
buttare via tutte queste mie conoscenze
non sarebbe possibile unire il motore a
combustione interna
l'elettrico le fonti rinnovabili
e vi dicessi che esiste un combustibile
chironi inquino
chi ha sentito parlare di carburanti
sintetici detti anche in fuel
vedo qualche mano alzata ma vedo anche
tante mani non alzate si tratta di
combustibile artificiali alla base un
combustibile è formato da idrogeno e
carbonio
l'idrogeno è quella sostanza che
troviamo comunemente nell'acqua il
carbonio lo troviamo sotto varie forme
ad esempio nell'area sotto la forma e di
anidride carbonica sarebbe possibile
estrarre idrogeno dall'acqua carbonio
dall'area combinarli e ottenere questo
combustibile artificiale
cisterne però tanta energia potremmo
usare energia rinnovabile pannelli
fotovoltaici avere tanta energia pulita
e gratuita e invece di andare ad
immagazzinare questa energia elettrica
nelle batterie che sono difficili da
gestire
potremmo immagazzinarli in questo
combustibile artificiale che potremo
distrib qui era in tutto il mondo dando
gli stessi oleodotti che abbiamo già e
distribuirlo vicino casa nostra dando le
stesse pompe di benzina che frase
scalate
immaginate di fra 15 anni vi svegliate
una domenica mattina andate nel vostro
garage trovate un'auto del tutto simile
a quella che avete già benzina diesel
metano la prendete andate a fare il
pieno di fuel nella pompa di benzina
dietro casa e poi vi muovete sulle
strade senza inquinare la chiave proprio
qui nostri inquino a differenza del
petrolio che quando è sotto terra nova
danno poi viene estratto viene bruciato
e libera nell'ambiente nell'atmosfera
tanti inquinanti tra cui l'anidride
carbonica
gli il fuel non inquinano
in teoria quando io brucio questo
combustibile sintetico vado a ridare
all'acqua l'idrogeno che chiesto in
prestito e vado ridare all'aria il
carbonio di asti imprese poco fa quindi
sulla carta il bilancio è nullo
partendo da fonti rinnovabili e quindi
possibile creare questo combustibile
sintetico che non inquina
io gli ho semplificato moltissimi
processi ma la ricerca stato il grande
anni questa direzione si stanno muovendo
anche grandi investitori come enel e
porsche potremmo anche andare oltre le
sue automobili una ricerca stima che
ricoprendo di pannelli fotovoltaici un
quarto del deserto del sahara
sarebbe possibile soddisfare l'intero
bisogno energetico mondiale
per concludere
il presente ci ordina ci impone di
rivedere la nostra idea di mobilità
dobbiamo puntare sulle elettrico e sul
rinnovabile ma non dovremmo trascurare
di investire nei motori a combustione
interna
proprio perché la migliore soluzione
potrebbe arrivare dal dalla
collaborazione tra queste diverse
tecnologie motore combustione interna
elettrico e rinnovabile
dopo tutta questa spiegazione quale auto
comprerete benzina diesel elettrico
aspettiamo di avere gli fuel nella pompa
di benzina dietro casa
non aspettiamo cent'anni
cerchiamo di realizzare la petizione di
iphone e raggiungiamo i nostri obiettivi
e nei prossimi 15 anni